vendredi dernier une professeur de
français a illustré son cours sur les
métaphores les métamorphoses d'Ovid avec
la présentation d'un tableau de guissp
Césari il ne s'agissait donc ni plus ni
moins d'une manière de lier deux arts la
peinture et la littérature depuis
pourtant cette professeur et l'ensemble
de l'équipe éducative ont demandé à
bénéficier de leur droit de retrait en
cause des élèves se sont insurgés contre
des propos ressentis comme raciste
accusation qu'ils ont pourtant depuis
reconnu comme étant mensongère trop mal
trop tard le mal été fait il ne s'agit
pas d'un simple fait divers et je crois
que cette cette situation est
l'illustration d'un problème plus
profond dans nos école celle de la
remise en question de notre principe de
laïcité monsieur le ministre ce sont
bien vos mots que je fais mien
aujourd'hui à l'école française on ne
conteste pas l'autorité on la respecte
école française on ne conteste pas la
laïcité on la respecte ce sont des
propos que nous devrions tous
saluer
pardon notre pays héritier des lumières
et de l'universalisme ne peut se laisser
enfermer dans de telles attaques nous
devons défendre nos notre principe de
laïcité qui je le rappelle impose le
respect de toutes les croyances
l'égalité de tous les citoyens devant la
loi sans distinction de religion et la
garantie par la République du du libre
exercice des cultes le principe de la
laïcité est un pilier de notre société
pour nos enfants l'école est un lieu de
son approtissage et ils doivent accepter
d'y construire leur esprit critique mais
ne doivent pas rejeter ce qu'ils
apprennent au nom de leur religion
quelle qu'elle soit réaffirmer
réaffirmons ensemble notre soutien à
l'ensemble des professeurs menacés et
remercionsles pour le courage de leur
engagement
merci